welcome back to the rockstars it's eric
boston phillip molina here with
bite size questions that you guys sent
in to us philip is gonna take these
these are just as important as hulk's
clapping
[Music]
no power important are you trying to
make me feel better about this
major danger 11 asked why did janet van
dyne age in the quantum realm when scott
lang stayed roughly the same age
paul rudd here actor and certified young
person okay so
a lot of people brought this up as a
plot hole actually they're like how come
janet says specifically i'm not the same
woman i was 30 years ago and she looks
30 years old
still tight but 30 years older she got
the silver streaks and then when
scotland goes in he
has skipped five years and it's been a
matter of minutes still very much
clueless paul read
yeah exactly it's like he does an age
what's most likely the answer in the
canon
is just based on the concept of the time
vortex right she specifically says look
out for time
vortices essentially right at the end of
ant-man and the wasp
and don't get sucked into a time vortex
we won't be able to save you
we do know that setting up end game the
creators of the film have confirmed
that that is the difference of the
experience that scott lang does
he goes in there and he does go through
a time vortex even though they didn't
show it to us they're like yeah
everybody got that right i don't know
that everybody did get that but
he went through a time vortex she did
not he skipped ahead five years
she did not she stayed there 30 years
but i actually think that there's a
slightly more interesting element to
this question
where if you think about the fact that
janet van dyne in the quantum realm
clearly lived a life in there right her
clothes are
developed in a way where she clearly has
had access to a sewing machine or
something right
here uh but she also was involved in the
civilization it kind of sounds like
we've multiple times pointed out that
city
in the quantum realm yeah under my
understanding i can imagine this city is
created
in a space in the quantum realm where
time is kind of secure within this
bubble
it's a safe place to house her for
people to live and live normally
outside of this bubble now you're in the
torrential storm
of the quantum realm where you know the
different sizes you are
create that relativity in time that
einstein theorized
any other area of the quantum realm also
might put you through time at a
different speed
than a nice secure safe place like that
city that's interesting yeah so
outside of the city there are these like
holes basically that these ditches that
you can fall into that suck you through
time right and aside from those holes
even just in general the quantum realm
is unstable in terms of a linear
timeline okay i
i like that answer at reef underscore 98
said
how does arthur fleck fire eight shots
from his gun without reloading and this
is a
joker yeah i remember this scene yeah
it's mistake mistake no it's not my full
answer actually so i did look into it
anyway i mean
probably a mistake right because we see
this in films although yeah the walking
dead rick is just from that point
endless
endless illness bullets
there is one interesting thing about
this film
maybe it's not a mistake so the gun he
uses is a
cult detective special the third
generation of that gun
absolutely is a six-shot
there are some revolvers that they can't
hold this one people theorized maybe
who's using an a uh shot one no it's
specifically should only be six that
could be the mistake or
it could be just one more clue that this
sequence might be imagined
we do know that this is some very large
spectacle
event that the news is covering to an
extent where everyone wants to know
who's killed these guys
it's the whole thomas wayne uh the fact
that he actually comes off as a villain
it's because he's sympathizing with kind
of the wrong side of
the class warfare and we do know that
joker's egomania his is putting him at
the center of things right
he imagines he goes on murray's show and
he's gonna be brought down from the
audience and he's gonna be the star of
the thing
the idea that he would be watching
something like this on the news and
imagine
that well what if it was me that killed
these guys which
is one of the scenes that is not
confirmed actually 100 that he was the
one that killed them
then that would make sense that he
actually doesn't understand
guns well enough to know how many shots
he would have he specifically when he's
given the gun
earlier he says that he's supposed to
stay away from those things
he clearly has been found to have mental
issues it wouldn't be surprising
if there is some sort of better
background check situation
in gotham than in the real world where
if you are established to be
someone of a certain mental state you're
not allowed to
have red flag laws exactly then he would
not have experience with these guns
so his guess is i don't know maybe he
has eight shots maybe he has endless
sure sure it's like fight club like he's
applying his own
understanding of how violence works to
his own life his imagination and then
you can still even use this argument
even if he was the guy that killed those
guys
then maybe just two the last two shots
weren't real yeah
like he walked up to it and plugged it
point blank range a couple more times
right so just those extra like cool
shots or something maybe those weren't
real
but probably just a mistake it's just a
mistake we have a question from caleb
taylor
in the infinity war opening scene why
does heimdall use the bifrost to save
hulk instead of thor
okay so this question actually was my
favorite one of this batch
there's kind of a straightforward answer
and then there's a interesting comics
lore answer the most straightforward
version of this is
that in this moment the asgardians at
what's left of them are there
heimdall is there hulk is there and
thanos and his peeps are there
in this moment heimdall decides i'm
going to send hulk
to earth as a warning basically now the
most simple
logic you can understand here is why
would he send thor
if thor is the leader and guardian
of the asgardians and here's the
potentially the final moment of the
asgardians you don't take away the
warrior who's there to defend the
asgardians
and send them to earth and now they're
like great hulk is here who doesn't give
a [ __ ] about us
if you just think of it as simply as
that thor doesn't have his guardian
goes down with the ship basically and
then hulk is an earthling
send him to earth right of all those
people so that's the easiest logic to
understand
except this is what i was thinking was
really interesting about it you also
have to remember in that moment
they're not on asgard they're not using
the traditional bifrost bridge
situation this room that is established
that they've used multiple times in the
mcu
in the comics the bifrost bridge is a
big deal to channel that
yeah and it uses that dark magic the
dark magic actually
is a destructive force that is very hard
to wield
in the comics when you send someone
through it you actually might kill them
it's it's
even thor it's very scary when you send
them
that way mcu hasn't really done it that
way except this
is now not in that controlled space
where they've designed it
to potentially even let you know rocket
raccoon uses it at one point so it
probably is like pretty safe when
heimdall straight up
says all father uh get you know send the
dark magic through me one last time
now we're talking about the raw energy
of this thing
in this version it actually might be
just like the comic version where he
says that exact same phrase
there's not a lot of entities that can
withstand that so heimdall himself can
though maybe it is killing him and you
know he's going to die anyway so it's
fine
hulk is one of the few creatures that
can probably also survive
this straight up dark magic flowing
right through him and sending
interesting so it's a difference of
using a
regulated microwave in your kitchen
versus using plutonium to cook
which is microwaved exactly yeah it
works great but uh
i do have this tail now and it's pretty
great and you're riddled with tumors
great thank you so much for sending your
questions folks and uh keep sending
those questions at bigquestion
and you can follow us on social media at
eavos at philip molina and you can
follow new rosters at new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube thank you so much for joining us
see you next week bye
[Music]
you